So, let's summarize what we have learned now. So
we, we first understood what is information and we
found out that information can be measured in some
way and we meausred it in terms of entropy.
Then we started to understand how we can measure
the information between two way variables. And there we
defined terms as, terms like joint entropy, conditional entropy
and mutual information. And then finally we introduced ourselves
to a term called a KL divergence, which
is very famously used as a distance measured between
two distributions. So this is just a primer
to information theory and it forms as a base
to what is required for you to go
through this machine learning course. If you want to
learn more about information theory, follow the links
in, in the Comments sections. And yeah. Thank you.